you both started out in same place
Thanks
you can't come back from this i knows
you can do people they always die I'm a
killer and you walk too right
[Music]
people in here they've been inside from
the start they haven't had to survive
they just don't get it
they can't
I don't take chances anymore then you
should listen
we'll make this work keep this place
safe help us
and keep our families safe so we're all
supposed to just fall in line behind you
soonish down not range now
how many more of us have to die
before we do something Rick is dangerous
these people they got to take care of
themselves feel different about it yeah
I'm no work like a stop we have to
people are scared
you should keep an eye on her
[Music]
she's in charge you're in charge now the
wound isn't what you thought it was you
don't know where you walk but you still
know your way
this is what life looks like now
we have to fight it as if we don't we
die he's been out there he's faced it we
are going to trust him all of us
you choosing this life you will die why
did you move it
to get the hell out of here and you
don't ever come back really think you're
gonna take this community from us
from Daryl from a shot
may the color do you have any idea who
you're talking to
[Music]
here's the deal you don't say [ __ ] and I
don't kill you do you think I am
hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Walking Dead Season 6
trailer breakdown just like my Doctor
Who trailer breakdown it's gonna be a
little janky audio only just because
there's so many videos going on
so the real thing that's going on this
season errors things get started is
Morgan in the safe zone versus the rick
tater ship Scott Gimple owned up to the
fact that they play with the narrative
in the trailers so even even though it
seems like Rick is saying you think you
can take this for me this community and
he might be talking to Morgan he's
probably talking to someone completely
different like the trailer just wants
you to think like they're gonna be
fighting each other literally the Morgan
versus Rick is is more of an ideological
difference I don't think they're
actually going to be slinging bolts at
each other
the villains as of the beginning of the
season are still the Wolves but people
said that they would be the solution to
a really interesting problem like it
wasn't just gonna be us you know
straight-up villain like they're not
strip just gonna drive up to Alexandria
and then the survivors are gonna try and
take him down some of the things they
said made it seem like the super heard
like the super Walker herd was gonna
become like a like a really huge problem
in that Rick in the survivors are the
the save some people I guess however you
want to think about him we're gonna try
and use the wolves to solve the problem
of the super pack remember they have
those 18 wheelers even though we saw an
18-wheeler in the trailer it might be a
different one or or it could have been
one of the ones packed with the W
walkers there are two new characters
that they announced there's ethan embry
and Merritt Wever
ethan embry seems like he might be
swinging things in a more chaotic
direction because Deanna and Rick have
come to an understanding Morgan is the
one who tries to show Deanna there's
another way he's like we need to be
careful about Rick but they're also
gonna be a bunch of flashbacks which is
what I think that big scene with Daryl
was at the end like it made it seem like
he was running into this other group of
people that might be the case but we
will be seeing flashbacks regardless it
was kind of like another funny Gimpo
moment where he's like yeah you know not
so many flashbacks not as many the last
year but then at the end of the panel he
was like you know what I forgot there
are a lot of flashbacks I was a little
surprised to see so much Enid in the
trailer
I guess that means that we'll be seeing
a lot of like Carl's narrative because
that's usually where that character
shows up like Enid exists to serve
Karl's narrative the other big
revelation is is that in the wake of
Risa's death and everything that
happened let the end of last season
Carroll is renewing her crusade to save
everyone so she's gonna be going into
like full-blown Rambo mode again she and
Daryl exist in this really interesting
state between you know what's going on
between Rick and Morgan you look at Rick
and Morgan is two different sides of
this ideology of like how they're gonna
save people Carol is the midpoint and
Daryl's not sure which way he's gonna go
I think he'd do whatever Carol told him
to do though go take a shower then go
ride your motorcycle some more but if
the trailer is any indication daryl is
not going to be swallowing any of Rick's
kool-aid as strong as those characters
all right I still are still really think
that their positioning like this is Rick
versus Morgan just just in terms of like
whose method is going to win out
Deanna's is like the powerful person in
the Alexandria safe zone but she's kind
of deferring to Morgan in the trailer so
I think that's gonna happen there's some
really cool new Walker designs I can't
wait to see some of these like he's
overgrown like green looking walkers
everyone always wonders like how long is
it gonna take before all the walkers
just to cake like the outbreak spreads
exponentially and then ends
exponentially because at a certain point
all these walkers are just gonna decay
into dust but I guess that's up to
Robert Kirkman and AMC how much they
dragged I doubt speaking of which Robert
Kirkman actually has a new show called
Al Castle on Showtime I'm gonna check it
out I'll at least do a video for the the
premiere but the other big stuff this
weekend is fear The Walking Dead so
there's like a trailer for that and the
panel I haven't uploaded any videos for
that yet but I do have that stuff like I
have the full panel and I'll do a
trailer video for that too fear The
Walking Dead starts August 23rd so I'll
be I'll be doing weekly episodes for
that will do the Walking Dead contest
they'll be great season six of the main
show starts October 11 like the second
week in October it's it's pretty much
week what we expected so there's not a
lot of huge surprises there so everybody
get really pumped for fear The Walking
Dead
by the time they get to the end of that
first season it's only six episodes they
will be in full-blown outbreak the [ __ ]
is gonna hit the fan over the course of
those six episodes if you guys aren't
huge fans of Kim Dickens already you
will be by at the end of that she's
she's amazing it's gonna be a lot of fun
and yes the timeline of that will catch
up with the main show but they don't
have any crossovers planned just because
one is taking place in Los Angeles
that's where fear The Walking Dead is
and the other is in DC so they're like
on opposite sides of the United State
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything today my next video is either
gonna be Batman vs Superman or a trailer
video for that like the panel or the
trailer there's just like so many videos
happening today and the big DC super
panel is tonight if you want to follow
me on Twitter and Facebook I'll be live
tweeting the panel's they're links for
that in the description below so I'll
see you guys a little bit everybody
let's high-five just do pretend like I'm
high-fiving the monitor right now